der stopp für astrazeneca wirbel
deutschlandsim pläne durcheinander ob er
wirklich nötig ist darüber streiten
experten und politiker was tun wenn die
inzidenz über 100 klettert manche städte
weigern sich wie vorgesehen die korona
notbremse zu ziehen
der e auto pionier und die probleme mit
der umwelt der wasserverbrauch der tesla
fabrik in brandenburg könnte den
geplanten ausbau verhindern
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
dienstag guten abend in allen sport hat
kristin otto heute für uns mit zwei
überraschungen guten abend für den
deutschen kampf gegen das virus ist es
ein schwerer rückschlag vorerst darf bei
uns niemand mehr mit dem impfstoff von
astrazeneca geimpft werden weil das
zuständige institut für die sicherheit
von impfstoffen das so empfohlen hatte
bis geklärt ist ob und wie
möglicherweise schwere fälle von
blutgerinnseln im hirn damit in
verbindung stehen
die entscheidung hat enorme folgen für
die deutschen im planungen wie wir jetzt
sehen können
bis anfang april soll deutschland noch
etwa 6,5 millionen impfdosen bekommen
die hälfte davon von biontech weiser
mehr als zwei millionen dosen von
astrazeneca mund gut eine million von
moderner ohne astrazeneca würde also
ziemlich genau ein drittel der in den
planungen vorgesehenen impfstoffe bis
ostern fehlen die gesamtzahl zurückgehen
christoph festival hat mehr dazu mit dem
siegeszeichen ins im zentrum hamburg
heute morgen kam die e mails wer schon
einen termin hat der wird auch geimpft
ausschließlich mit biontech solange der
vorrat reicht zwei wochen etwa das ist
gut für die vorgemerkten vielleicht auch
anderswo für alle anderen für das
deutsche impfprogramm ist dies ein
schwarzer tag
wir sind gerade dabei die impfkampagne
in die praxen auszurollen und da stand
natürlich aus der khl mittelpunkt jetzt
haben wir ungefähr die hälfte unserer
kapazitäten verloren sicherheit geht
eben vor heißt es aber wie groß ist das
risiko überhaupt einige zahlen helfen
bei der einschätzung 1,6 millionen mal
wurde astrazeneca in deutschland schon
verimpft dabei soll es zu acht hirn
venenthrombosen gekommen sein
fast nur bei frauen mittleren alters die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es einen
geimpften trifft liegt also bei 1 zu
200.000 wahr ist aber auch bei diesen
sehr seltenen thrombosen wären
eigentlich drei bis fünf fälle auf eine
million einwohner zu erwarten pro jahr
unter den astra zeneca geimpften sind es
wie gesagt schon acht ihn gerade fünf
wochen was passiert da ihm hören das
blut verklumpt in den venen bei frauen
dreimal häufiger als bei mir
das größte risiko haben jüngere so um
die 30 jährige die symptome starke
kopfschmerzen krampfanfälle sehstörungen
rechtzeitig erkannt kann die thrombose
aber gut behandelt werden für alle schon
geimpften heißt dass eine woche
aufmerksam und vorsichtig sein man kann
prinzipiell sagen dass die fälle sehr
selten auftreten und dass wenn man nicht
nach den impfungen in den ersten tagen
schwerwiegende nebenwirkungen hat dann
treten auch keine nebenwirkungen zum
späteren zeitpunkt auf wie es jetzt
weitergeht
ärzte vermuten astrazeneca wird schnell
wieder freigegeben werden
die frage ist wie werden wir ihn dann
einsetzen wie wird er akzeptiert werden
übermorgen soll die entscheidung fallen
bei der europäischen arzneimittelagentur
ema klar ist astrazeneca erstmal zu
stoppen das war eine entscheidung mit
folgen klar ist auch sie würde
umstritten sein
eine unglückliche entscheidung sagen die
einen
wenn das imk institut so was empfiehlt
sollte die politik dem folgen das sagen
die anderen
über die politische diskussion jetzt
patricia wiedemeier auch im zentrum der
stadt köln gähnende leere jedenfalls
dort wo mit astrazeneca geimpft werden
sollte der ärger über die berliner
entscheidung entsprechend groß das
vertrauen jetzt wieder herzustellen ist
sicherlich die größte aufgabe die jetzt
vor uns liegt
unverständnis auch bei der opposition in
berlin
heute hat die europäische behörde noch
einmal festgehalten dass sie findet dass
der wirkstoff arnica weiter vertieft
werden kann während der prüfung über die
nebenwirkungen mir ist und bleibt
schleierhaft wie herr spahn gestern zu
seiner entscheidung gekommen ist wir
erleben ein absolutes versagen in dieser
pandemie es ist ein tiefpunkt ich
fordere dass der impfstoff astrazeneca
an diejenigen die geimpft werden wollen
auch weiterhin verimpft werden kann
die reaktionen aus den bundesländern
sehr unterschiedlich manuela schwesig zb
will jetzt bei montech impfdosen die für
die zweite impfung zurückgehalten boden
nutzen
eine 50-prozentige rücklage mehr bilden
sondern eine 20-prozentige das ist die
empfehlung auch des bundes weil die
biontech lieferung jetzt doch stabiler
und verlässlicher sind markus söder will
das eben von generell beschleunigen
unser ziel ist auch beim ausfall von
astrazeneca hausärzte zu beteiligen
wir glauben dass insbesondere in
hotspots des ein guter weg sein kann und
armin laschet bürokratie beim impfen
abbauen
es ist sehr viele formulare auszufüllen
manches ist notwendig aber es geht
glaube ich auch schlanker und
unbürokratischer die diskussion um
astrazeneca mal wieder viel stoff für
den impf gipfel der stadt morgen abend
jetzt wohl am freitag stattfinden wird
viele neue fragen zum impfen also und
gleichzeitig steigen die korona zahlen
weiter das robert koch institut meldet
heute 5480 neuinfektionen innerhalb von
24 stunden das sind 1228 mehr als
vergangenen dienstag 238 menschen
starben an oder mit dem virus
die bundesweite inzidenz liegt mit 83,7
leicht höher als gestern in immer mehr
regionen steigt diese incident auch
schon über 100 eigentlich soll dann in
kreisen und städten eine sogenannte
notbremse greifen mit beschränkungen bei
privaten treffen beim unterricht beim
einkaufen aber nicht alle halten sich
daran
beispiel brandenburg das land beschloss
dass eine automatische notbremse erst ab
200 gilt beispiel herne die stadt ist in
nordrhein westfalen mit 157,9 inzidenz
spitzenreiter die notbremse zieht sie
aber nicht thomas münten wochenmarkt in
herne seit sechs tagen geist die stadt
die hundertermarke trotzdem bleibt erst
einmal alles vorsichtig offen
viele bürger fühlen sich damit die eher
unwohl
heute ist ja nicht mein herne so man
sieht den bundesweiten trend über
steigende zahlen und trotzdem überbieten
sich gerade mit logo das ist
unverantwortlich
das sieht der landrat im kreis düren
inzidenz 126,2 ähnlich und fragt sich
immer öfter wie er denn nun handeln soll
ja das verursacht mir graue haare und
ich hatte fest verinnerlicht dass bei
einem wert von 100 oder wenn dieser wert
100 in der inzidenz überschritten wird
das dann maßnahmen greifen und das
scheint jetzt außer kraft gesetzt werden
vom nrw gesundheitsminister kam dazu
heute nichts
am wochenende ließ er mitteilen wenn
alleine durch die vielen zusätzlichen
testungen die zahlen steigen muss man
das bei den weiteren bewertungen mit
einbeziehen
der chefideologe der uniklinik essen
setzt unterdessen auf die impfungen
sie zeigt nun erste wirkungen die ganze
zeit bisher waren die neuinfektionen
gekoppelt an das was wir letztendlich
dann im krankenhaus gesehen haben
da sehen wir hoffentlich in zukunft eine
entkopplung und deswegen brauchen wir
weitere werte wie wir bedenken bevor wir
einen weiteren lockdown einleiten
in herne ist die inzidenz in den letzten
zwei tagen leicht gesunken dass dieser
trend anhält darauf hoffen sie hier
steigender corona zahlen und die folgen
des impfstoffs dazu gibt es gleich ein
zdf spezial gleich nach uns hier und
jetzt unser nächstes thema in dieser
sendung besser als erwartet so zieht der
vw konzern heute bilanz des corona
jahres 2020 und in den nächsten jahren
will volkswagen weltmarktführer bei den
elektrofahrzeugen werden und investiert
dafür bis 2026 35 milliarden euro bis
2030 sollen eigene giga fabriken für
batteriezellen entstehen
die wolfsburger haben dabei den
marktführer tesla im blick oliver deuker
volkswagen boss herbert diess wirkt
äußerst zufrieden kein wunder kann er
doch einen gewinn nach steuern von 8,8
milliarden euro präsentieren
trotz der nachwirkungen der diesel
affäre der korona pany und die
milliardenteuren umbau zu elektro
mobilität elektromobilität wird jetzt in
dem maße auch nicht mehr diskutiert hat
sich durchgesetzt wir sind auf dem
richtigen weg vorgegeben hat diesen weg
die eu die mit immer niedrigeren co2
grenzen die autobauer weg von den
verbrenner motoren zwingt sonst drohen
milliardenschwere strafzahlungen
zwar ist volkswagen spät in die
e-mobilität eingestiegen aber nun mit
volldampf dabei wirkte die diesel affäre
wie ein katalysator
volkswagen hat mit sicherheit die
pionierrolle im bereich elektromobilität
verschlafen
wenn es jetzt aber um die
industrialisierung geht wirklich
massenfertigung von elektrofahrzeugen
dann ist volkswagen vorne dabei
das will volkswagen auch in der
batterieproduktion sein bis 2030 sollen
in europa sechs eigene werke entstehen
ziel unabhängigkeit geringere kosten
es wird für den kunden kostengünstiger
seien elektrisch zu fahren es gibt er
anzeichen dass man mit elektrofahrzeugen
durchaus mehr geld verdienen kann als
mit verbrennen wenn denn der kunde die e
fahrzeuge in massen kaufen wird in
europa und den usa herrscht derzeit noch
große zurückhaltung es ist eine wette
auf die zukunft das weiß man auch bei
volkswagen bringt man auch peter kunst
mit dazu live in wolfsburg und nahmen
peter das ist eine strategie die jetzt
auch aufgehen muss bei 35 milliarden
investitionen
wo liegen denn die größten hürden für vw
die größte hürde ist im grunde genannt
worden käufer müssen überzeugt werden
elektrische autos auch kaufen zu wollen
dafür müssen die billiger werden
schneller laden können mehr reichweite
haben für all das hat volkswagen chef
dies ja offenbar einen plan vor allen
dingen mit einer ganz neuen generation
der produzieren will
dies spielt ganz und gar auf sieg auf
masse auf stückzahl
er will die anderen im sinn des wortes
überrollen schafft volkswagen das nicht
um strauchelt dann wird es allerdings
gefährlich denn das sind derzeit beim
umbau des autos nicht die riesen die
überleben nicht automatisch zumindest
sind die schlauen und dies versucht
beides zu sein riese und schlau
dafür braucht er aber auch viele
software experten die fehlen volkswagen
auch noch und das ist dann auch eine
hürde die man hier
in wolfsburg noch nehmen muss peter kunz
zdf wolfsburg herzlichen dank für diese
hintergrundinformationen wir bleiben im
moment beim thema auch vw rivale tesla
investiert milliarden in deutschland in
brandenburg entsteht eine riesige fabrik
des amerikanischen e auto pioniers tesla
chef elon musk drückt aufs tempo
umweltschützer und anwohner befürchten
ausgerechnet bei einem zukunftsweisenden
projekt negative folgen für die umwelt
vor allem das wasser könnte knapp werden
manche reise mit mehr im februar 2020
wurden hier im brandenburgischen
grünheide 92 hektar wald gefällt für die
neue tesla autofabrik 500.000 autos
sollen im jahr produziert werden für die
produktion braucht tesla viel wasser
zunächst 1,4 millionen kubikmeter das
ist so viel wie der bedarf einer 40.000
einwohner stadt
doch tesla will irgendwann noch mehr
autos bauen und eine batteriefabrik
dafür fehlt aber das wasser in der regen
am region sagt der chef des zuständigen
wasserwerks beginnt jetzt seit ich davon
aus und das ist auch das was wir schon
vor anderthalb jahren wussten und auch
gesagt haben dass anfang 23 die mengen
die dort gebraucht werden für die
produktion das was wir zur verfügung
stellen können übersteigen werden
vergangenen sommer auf der baustelle
tesla chef elon musk ist zu besuch er
sieht keine probleme
ich meine diese bäume hier würden ja
nicht wachsen wenn es kein wasser gäbe
ich meine wir sind hier nicht in der
wüste der brandenburgische
umweltminister stellt sich den fragen
der anwohner und gibt zu dass das wasser
für einen weiteren ausbau der tesla
fabrik zum problem werden könnte wenn es
noch darüber hinausgehen sollte ja da
muss man eben gucken also dann gibt es
entweder die variante dass entwicklung
nicht stattfinden weiß test leider ist
auch natürlich weiß er dass ab juli
seien hier in brandenburg grünheide
schon die ersten autos vom band rollen
viel mehr dazu heute abend bei frontal21
im zdf 21 uhr 10
deutschland hat sein zwischenzeitlich
abgeschriebenes klimaziele für 2020 doch
noch erreicht ein positiver effekt denn
die fabriken produzierten wegen des lok
bei uns weniger und es waren weniger
flugzeuge und autos unterwegs
im vergangenen jahr wurden 70 millionen
tonnen weniger treibhausgase freigesetzt
als 2009/10 berichtet umweltministerin
svenja schulze
das bedeutet ein minus von 8,7 prozent
im vergleich zu 1990 sanken die
emissionen in deutschland um 40,8
prozent ganz anderes thema jetzt in
dieser sendung wir sollten nach
äthiopien schauen auf einen blutigen
konflikt der tausende in die flucht
treibt von massakern und
vergewaltigungen berichten augenzeugen
seit monaten wird in äthiopien gekämpft
und zwar um die region t3 truppen der
äthiopischen zentralregierung hat eine
offensive gestartet gegen lokale milizen
es gebe fälle von ethnischen säuberungen
sagt die us regierung hunderttausende
menschen brauchen hilfe
unser korrespondent tim kröger war vor
ort die spuren des konflikt sind
deutlich sichtbar auf unserer fahrt
durch die krisenregion t3 zumindest in
größeren städten herrscht mitunter
wieder ein wenig normalität aber das ist
nur die eine seite
immer wieder hören wir von ermordungen
vertreibungen plünderungen
vergewaltigungen in einem krankenhaus
treffen wir eine junge frau die von
irischen soldaten schwer missbraucht
wurde wie sie erzählt und sagen also
nicht vergewaltigten war ich bei
bewusstsein
ich habe die ganze zeit über geschrien
habe nicht aufgehört dann gaben sie mir
drogen seit november tobt der konflikt
nationale truppen gegenkräfte der
früheren regionalregierung offenbar
unterstützt von milizen und soldaten des
nachbarlandes eritrea die so oft leiden
die einfachen menschen am meisten
in vielen regionen fehlt es an
lebensmitteln medikamenten wasser
wenigstens etwas hilfe kommt
mittlerweile an eritreische soldaten
kamen in unser dorf namen unser essen
unsere tiere
nahmen unsere zwei kühe alles was wir
hatten ich kam in die stadt um mein
leben zu retten
wie er sind tausende vertrieben worden
viele von ihnen sind in der stadt ihre
gestrandet auch die menschen hier haben
offenbar schlimmes erlebt es ist
unglaublich wie wir hier für den
menschen bedrängt werden jeder hier bin
und eine geschichte erzählen hört zu
bitte hört zu wie ihr leiden sie haben
meinen sohn getötet das ist seine frau
wir sind vertrieben worden aus unserem
zuhause also müssen wir jetzt hungern
wir haben unser heim unsere heimat
verloren
es soll sogar zu massakern gekommen sein
das ganze ausmass der situation integra
aber ist auch vor ort schwer zu fassen
vor allem in den ländlichen regionen
zurück nach deutschland die bremer bank
greencell tochter eines britisch
australischen finanzkonzerns ist wohl
nicht mehr zu retten
das insolvenzverfahren ist eröffnet und
die kunden fürchten um ihr geld
wenn banken pleite gehen greift die
einlagensicherung das guthaben von
privatleuten ist bis zu einer gewissen
höhe sicher das problem bei green so
einige deutsche kommunen hatten geld
dort deponiert und die fallen nicht
unter den gesetzlichen schutzschirm
alexander fettich emmerich am rhein
zittert um sechs millionen euro
auch die stadt an der niederländischen
grenze hatte bei green 10 angelegt der
grund greens lockte wenigstens mit
minimalen zinsen statt der sonst
üblichen strafzinsen das heißt
durchschnittlich bezahlen wir für eine
million euro liquider mittel die wir an
legen 0,5 prozent negativzinsen
intentionen war genau diese zinsen zu
vermeiden
ob wiesbaden oder das rheinische monheim
auf greens hill vertrauten viele 2009 10
hatte greencell noch sehr gute noten bei
den ratingagenturen auf das land
thüringen legte damals 50 millionen an
zum zeitpunkt der anlage 2009/10 konnten
wir keine unterlagen finden dass wir
misstrauen hätten haben müssen also die
bank war gerettet da gab es keine
auffälligkeit doch die finanzaufseher
der bafin schöpften im frühjahr 2020
verdacht sie dürfen solche reinen
verdachtsfälle aber nicht öffentlich
machen und so investierten mancher
kämmerer noch im februar bei der
kriselnden bank dabei wurde in
finanzkreisen schon kritisch über sie
gesprochen
der angebotene zinssatz durch diese bank
war ja äußerst attraktiv er war ja auch
ein alleinstellungsmerkmal das heißt
niemand ansonsten hat solche zinsen
angeboten das allein hätte aus meiner
sicht schon warnung genug sein müssen
doch auch die stadt emmerich hat noch im
februar bei green sind investiert das
geld ihrer bürger ist nun wohl
größtenteils verloren und jetzt in der
sendung schnitt und ab zum sport
los geht's mit fußball champions league
woche morgen abend das achtelfinal
rückspiel des deutschen rekordmeisters
bayern münchen gegen lazio rom mit dem
vorteil des 4 zu 1 hinspielsieges und
der frage ob der angeschlagene manuel
neuer im tor ersetzt wird darf er mal
wieder ins bayern tor
es wäre das dritte pflichtspiel erst für
alexander nübel im bayern-dress sollte
neuer tatsächlich ausfallen
nach dem 4 2 1 aus rom wollen die bayern
weiter unbesiegt bleiben
18 spiele sind es jetzt in der
championsleague dass hansi flick als
nachfolger infrage käme auch heute thema
in münchen wieder mal
obwohl bayern chef rummenigge schon
abgeblockt hat und flix selbst zu seinem
standardsatz greift bei mir hat sich
nichts geändert ich hab' ich habe gesagt
alles ich habe alles gesagt was es zu
sagen habe und deswegen tue ich mich zu
dem thema äußern
immerhin die möglichkeit bundestrainer
zu werden bietet sich vielleicht nur
einmal im leben
bundestrainer joachim löw plant die
talente jamal musealer von bayern
münchen und florian würz von bayer
leverkusen erstmalig in sein aufgebot zu
berufen
für die kommenden drei länderspiele
gegen island rumänien und nord
mazedonien ende märz bereits vier jahre
älter als diese beiden jungstars
zusammen nämlich 39 jahre ist der
prominente rückkehrer in schwedens
national
mannschaft zlatan ibrahimovic der
stürmer vom ac mailand hatte 2016 seinen
rücktritt erklärt einen ganz aktuellen
und überraschenden rückzug gibt es im
biathlon ein knappes jahr vor winter
olympia in peking beendet an peiffer
seine karriere
der 33 jährige gewann seit 2009
insgesamt 20 medaillen bei
großereignissen darunter olympisches
gold im sprint bei den winterspielen
2018 in pyeongchang sowie fünf
weltmeistertitel zuletzt freute er sich
im februar bei der wm in pokljuka über
silber im einzel aber jetzt sei der
ideale zeitpunkt um aufzuhören
tja ein typ der garantiert findet aber
immerhin hat er 20 medaillen im schrank
das ist wirklich sehenswert absolut
vielen dank christian so archäologen
sind ja auch so was wie schatzsucher und
die in der wüste am toten meer haben
jetzt einen aufsehen erregenden fund
gemacht die kulisse sieht ein bisschen
aus wie im film viel felshöhlen steile
treppen exakt dort fanden die forscher
reste einer 2000 jahre alten
schriftrollen mit biblischen texten als
ältester schatz weltweit gilt aber
dieser korb mit deckel ebenfalls dort
ausgegraben
er ist aus gewebtem schilf und älter als
10.000 jahre
da fühlt man sich plötzlich ganz klein
schnell noch einen blick aufs wetter mit
katja horneffer es bleibt kalt gibt aber
mehr sonne und weniger schnee jetzt
gleich nach uns ein zdf spezial wie
bereits erwähnt dann natürlich das heute
journal mit dem kollegen claus kleber
heute um drei minuten vor 10 morgen
freut sich hier petra gerster auf 7 ich
danke für das interesse und wünsche im
namen des gesamten teams der heute 19
in allen einen angenehmen haben
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
zwischen dem tief hier über dem bosporus
in dem hoch über großbritannien bleibt
es auch morgen bei uns kalt es gibt
weitere schnee regen und schneeschauer
auch heute nacht schneit es noch vor
allen dingen an den alpen und es sind
noch einige schauer unterwegs machen sie
sich auf winterliche straßenverhältnisse
gefasst denn die temperaturen sinken zum
teil bis minus 4 grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 0 grad direkt am alpenrand und
9 grad hier an der elbe und auch morgen
schneit es noch aber die sonne hat auch
deutlich mehr anteile als heute es gibt
noch einige schauer bei einem leichten
wind aus nördlichen richtungen
am donnerstag kommt dann das nächste
schneeregen tief von nordwesten heran
das zieht weiter richtung südosten bei
17 grad und am freitag ziehen sich die
schneefälle immer mehr in den südosten
zurück der samstag wird dann trocken
schönen abend noch